Hello?
Hi, Amanda.
How are you feeling this morning?
I'm tired. I can barely talk.
What's wrong?
I couldn't get a good night's sleep.
Why not?
I've just started a part-time job.
Oh, what kind of job is that?
I actually have two different part-time jobs.
One is babysitting, and the other is tutoring.
Wow, those will keep you busy.
Yes, that's why I'm so tired.
How old is the kid you're babysitting?
I'm babysitting two kids.
One is 3 years old, and the other is 5 years old.
Isn't it hard to handle two of them at the same time?
Yes, it can be very difficult, but they are cute.
Are you also teaching them as a tutor?
No, I'm tutoring a high school student.
What subject are you teaching?
I'm teaching mathematics.
I didn't know you're good with numbers.